[Music]
in backlashed s a new clash essay
submitted by fire and ice when the Lord
comes into your life and he touches your
soul do you shut that door I don't think
so you say Jesus I am ready for you
Jesus you say Jesus I am here to accept
your anointing and if I choose to shut
you out I must take that responsibility
there are times in your life when you
will wake up and you may not want to
open your eyes
but God will be there by your side
telling you my child come to me put your
burdens upon me you do not need to carry
that for yourself I am here for you my
child why you have Satan in your ear
talking like this hey maybe you should
do drugs but you tell Satan no more hey
the Reverend here we go and then you cue
the music a mommy blogger refuses to
stop bullshitting refuses to stop
publishing stuff about motherhood
despite her daughter's please yes same
things bullshitting oh [ __ ]
so the daughters are like mom you need
to stop [ __ ] posting [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up
and she's like nope this is my child
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] what is she
publishing is it like phony advice like
or is it embarrassing the kids yeah like
her vaginal issues oh god damn this
daughter daughters kind of yeasty
No awesome
the yeasty bacterias yeast in West yeast
Noren Saints yeah and what else they
have three right we have room for East
yeast yeah and in the last one is
compass compass West because it was is
it that like what's embarrassing if we
have another child he has another one
coming no there's three right now what's
the other kids not pregnant she's pretty
good home she looking fierce how about
you wanna bet she's pregnant again
really a hundred dollars
farts money bart's bunny allah Bart's
cash that she's pregnant again looking
up right now serving right now I know
what sin you want so what's going on
with this mom controversy Wow Joe we
didn't put us back on track
Kardashian pregnant you know we're
[ __ ] up when Joe has to steer the car
see that's true
Joe's like this is out of control having
a baby boy you know where she hides the
baby in her ass probably that's where
she gives birth I don't know she has a
surrogate oh but she having a kid though
right also she's having a kid without
having both right boy I guess like if
you had the money and you don't want to
ravage your body again I did it's
already ravaged though oh yeah no it's
not
well did you see the dick on Ray J that
[ __ ] was ravaged kid everybody wants to
see Kim at that time she was fine as
[ __ ] no I think she's pretty fine out
now her ass is weird her [ __ ] looks
weird
I was getting so frustrated at how they
were recording it all like show me some
penetration guys do this only like maybe
like 12 seconds that's enjoyable I've
never seen a sex tape yeah I mean it's
already the time is Ray J doing this I
want to see celebrity sex tapes cuz
they're not the professional so it's
gonna look back like I want that
professional [ __ ] dude well I guess what
this mommy blogger though no one gives a
[ __ ] about this I know I just give a
[ __ ] about their money [ __ ] about them
this blogger do wise the daughters in
shut the hell up okay so the daughter's
nine years old
Oh her birth for Christmas or some [ __ ]
she gave her a laptop with parental
controls and all this stuff she can't
she was like I'm the only one that
didn't have my own device so then they
gave her that right yeah and then the
first thing she did was google her
mother's name and she discovered many
articles and images of herself including
accounts of toilet training and tantrums
because her mother is a mommy blogger
who writes about her personal life and
publications and the New York Times
Motherwell and Chicago Tribune damn and
and also Jim post should be venting
about her daughter she gets work yeah
and so she report their most recent
essay for a Washington Post
it's entitled my daughter asked me to
stop writing about motherhood here's why
I can't do that he wrote about that too
dude that's [ __ ] funny she's like mom
I need to talk to you real quick once
again tell me yeah no she's just seeming
like my daughter walked up to me hi dr.
Sundra stop reading the stuff they're
typing right now she's hash tagging all
the brands judo
at her cabin as she dress actually
begins to yell at me I'm starting to
feel uncomfortable we go so she was
saying that um her daughter like
demanded an explanation
Oh millennial [ __ ] [ __ ] is this dude
what I don't know if it's Millennials
it's 99 maybe the mom is she's 9 maybe
the mom is a millennia I don't know but
then the point is that laptop is buck
through her [ __ ] expectation of the
data
she should be thankful right more [ __ ]
about me and buy more laptops for me
yeah I'm confused maybe the child didn't
even know that her mom was a blogger
holy the daughter knows yeah I don't
think those kids know I didn't really
know what my parents did I think knows
what if does know what's gonna happen
dude watch there's only one kid there
was four of us some like I was just
raised by my brother in a couple bases
is what's gonna happen you're gonna be
in your [ __ ] living room watching a
TV and then Tyga is gonna be like this
on the phone you want money
yeah how does it sound like
we want to go to school you want to
study a lot because yeah I think about
the kids like cuz I put my kid on blast
uh and I think about that all the
possible surgery method aren't we remind
me of our plan we're like what's to get
all people right now you rearrange your
face oh yeah that's what he says his
plan are you pre playing his plastic
surgery yet no but yeah so wonder the
really attractive but what if he's like
so handsome and then there's like
literally nothing you could do and it
just makes them ugly boy just make Missa
tee yeah i'ma leave my kids out the
limelight cuz I don't want them to be
more popular than me
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what it's not that hard I hope
you know I hope you know what are you
saying hope you hold the knobs a mom
probably fan alright get off his back
obviously much let's move on policing
alright so anyway so the daughter asked
like hey you know can you take these
articles and my photos down oh wow
that's that's a nine year old you don't
[ __ ] talk to me like that you son of
a get that [ __ ] receipt [ __ ]
you're on care of my daughter
he's fidgety huh no way she asked
Gerry's just so she asked her that and
then that the writer mom said that's not
possible and then that there was heavy
sighing and a slam door and then a slam
door you don't slam your [ __ ] dog
that's some disrespect dude she's nine
so she probably on her period a fourth
grader it's possible true of the
earliest I've heard is nine eight oh
that sounds like some PMS move later
she's like bucket bleeding all over the
place could be she could be PMS and
ready anyways the venture that's a hard
one so then she the mom says that she
found articles about other writers and
that what they ended up doing in this
situation is that they just gave up
writing about their children when they
reached a certain age but for her she's
like I respect that approach and I
understand why it works for them but
that's a promise I can't make because
writing about that's about her anymore
would mean shutting down a vital part of
myself which isn't necessarily good for
me or her what about taking out the name
just same way well you got some now so
be it did reach a compromise so now the
mom is gonna tell her like a pretty much
like an ownership of what she's writing
and then make sure it's all this whole
key details of her daughter please yeah
yeah and then also it's true she's gonna
use her daughter's new alias yeah alias
and Sparkle
[Music]
sparkles twinkle toes but yeah and so
come Betty Jack's writing about all this
right teddy
fire that sounds like a fierce name
what's up come fatty what we doing
tonight
you know our alter ego Oh confetti check
because I got skates now get into
tonight
Turkey Rochelle Rochelle that's what the
girl
Rochelle you don't name all Sudan but
yes oh then she wrote all that but this
essay got backlash like [ __ ] I do miss
that test that I first met what you'd be
like Isaac like you like it
I think Amir I sick Amir yeah he met me
like four times you look so different
though I said I look at old videos that
when you first started coming in and I'm
like oh my god no wonder David's name at
all no wonder David is abrasive
you look very much the type of art Kelly
would like very young 12 year old I have
a confession TIFF what I thought you had
a lazy eye that you take to the grave it
would have made no difference but I'm
glad you told me what made you think
that because for the first few years I
was just looked and then I'd be like
years mmm Casey's girl forgot a lazy eye
she can't look straight
oh wait a minute Joe we know you have a
problem with licking the people straight
in the eye so maybe it's you that's so
true cuz you and he will literally look
at me for two seconds and look away yeah
cuz I thought you had a lazy eye I
didn't want to scare I didn't want to
stay just like I was just like oh oh I
was like does Casey know this lazy eyes
when your Y eyes are wide open but one
is looking the other way
yeah no no it's win one I just kind of
yeah I have no idea I really don't know
yeah yeah I really don't know and then
like I think I actually started looking
and I was like oh okay so long I was
like because every time I would like
look over but I can't I can't I can't
cuz it's like if someone has a ball I
don't know I don't know why my brain
thought that but we're like this
confession for the longest time though I
was just like okay I don't want to I
want her to be self-conscious so I
didn't want to lazy eye face you don't
obviously you don't know but like every
time and it was severe like in my brain
wide open like this but then it was it
was it was veering off to the side like
a goldfish we made so many videos I know
like evidence no no before you were in
the videos a whole solid year like yeah
that's funny
damn I wish I had some recordings of the
way you used to speak because I would
like to listen to them baby videos those
one
I think you're right now whoo yeah 9si
phone pretty much pretty much you might
as well play nice on Isaac's first words
Holmes yeah I feel like Isaac what you
crying Oh like what you crying
what oh no I was gonna say so this is
sega background so for example is one
tweet says and now your daughter will
know that you are not to be trusted with
secrets and personal details way to ruin
mother-daughter [ __ ] you shut up you
[ __ ]
yeah yeah she got her a [ __ ] laptop
what do you do for your kid huh and then
this oh no wasting your time reading the
[ __ ] newspaper and spent time with
your kids
yeah newspapers it means that yeah at
Washington Post please consider removing
Christie tape from your website and your
employee you are complicit in and
profiting from a manipulative narcissist
emitted narcissist submitted emotional
abuse of a child come on fake her child
as that would imply this wretched
scumbag as a mother
dude lady go get some [ __ ] dude oh
dude guy get some dick dude guy I mean
let's go back to how you used to speak
this is better what how all of us used
to speak how do we well I used to have a
cholo me apart if you look at our old
light yeah it's still something like do
you guys sound worried told him both of
us combined
really today I don't think I ever saw
exactly okay all right exactly
I'm the only proper sleeping one out of
all you things I speak properly
converting I speak properly man yeah
real good my voice never changed really
she been white that's what she's trying
to say why you can properly the right
way
I'm pure as cocaine [ __ ]
[Music]